el servicio obstetricia que dirige
Analía messina a las personas gestantes
pueden acceder a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo hasta las 14
semanas de gestación pero en ciertos
casos también pueden abortar después de
ese lapso de tiempo en este consultorio
se hace toda la parte de asesoramiento
consejería y se entrega la medicación el
cambio en la ley no solo vino acompañado
de un mejor acceso a la práctica sino
también de mejor provisión de insumos
incluido el tratamiento de medicamentos
combinados recomendados por la
Organización Mundial de la Salud por
suerte contamos ahora con vipac que es
mifepristona más misoprostol También
tenemos misoprostol que es un insumo
absolutamente imprescindible que el
aborto tenga lugar en este contexto
permite además Dar seguimiento a los
casos que lo necesitan es que uno de los
objetivos de la ley era reducir la
mortalidad y las secuelas en personas
que abortan al ofrecer un marco seguro
para la práctica en un creciente número
de sectores de salud Hoy hay 1443 centro
de salud y hospitales públicos que
garantizan iveil en todo el país es un
60 más de lo que estaba declarado 60%
más de lo que estaba declarado en 2020
que eran 903 cuando se registran las
muertes relacionados aborto estamos en
el en el momento más bajo y hubo una
reducción del 40 por ciento pero a pesar
de estos avances Todavía existen
barreras en algunos casos como cuenta
Liliana piñeiro que pertenece a una red
autogestionada que brinda apoyo y
acompañamiento a personas que quieren
abortar si bien hay más equipos y todo
también hay más personas objetoras
dentro de esos espacios
llevándolo adelante no entonces hay
dilación
el hecho de hacerles esperar generar
estudios que no son necesarios Tal vez
así que en 2021 con la ley ya vigente
socorristas en Red brindó acompañamiento
a más de 11.500 personas en toda
Argentina que quisieron abortar